playing war is an advocate for the
Second Amendment he's seen a lot of
these probably not shocked as we are
joins us tonight to respond to it
um this does seem even by the standards
of the disarm the population group this
does seem pretty Shameless
no it really is especially considering
the amount of information that people
have now with respect to the stats like
the vast majority of these shootings are
committed with handguns I mean we're
talking the vast majority so for them to
follow it up immediately after and talk
about what is used a fraction of the
time of the shootings it kind of speaks
very loudly to how disingenuous they are
about actually looking for a solution
they're trying to get a goal and the
goal essentially is to get gun control
that's really all they care about so
it's almost as if they wait for these
types of tragedies to happen so that
they can leverage it to get their goal
because if we were talking Solutions we
wouldn't be talking about a gun that's
used a fraction of the time in these
types of shootings we'd be talking about
okay how do we take what are soft
targets and make them hard we're like
that's not even mentioned and then when
it's brought up they say things like
well we don't want our schools to look
like prisons why are we talking
Aesthetics when we're talking about the
safety of our children
can I ask a question like what if you
really cared about the murder of
innocence and I think most people I do
people who disagree with me and
everything I think people do care but if
you were rational about it you would
want to know all the factors that led to
it and you'd want a talk screen from the
blood of the killer like a lot of these
people seem like they're not an awful
lot of pharmaceuticals what others
Pharmaceuticals why can't we know that
and if they describe their motive in
writing in a Manifesto why can't we see
that I don't understand I mean we're
being lied to well the children haven't
even been buried yet I don't know why no
one else is offended by that
you know that's interesting you said
that Tucker I actually was talking with
a good friend of mine and he stated the
same thing he was like all of these
things have been released to us rather
quickly we have the video of the cops um
actually taking down the suspect we have
all of this information except for the
information that really matters most to
get to the deeper issue involved here
but you got to think about the type of
mentality and mindset of somebody who
can look at a child point a gun at them
and pull the trigger that's dark or
possibly there's something else going on
here but we don't know we can't get any
insight because as you pointed out
Simply we don't have that information
and they don't want to give it to us
but they never want to explain why
anything happens why did 9 11 happen I
still don't know I honestly don't I mean
that they hate our freedoms okay but
what's the really was there more to it
than that why did Russia invade Ukraine
it seemed like kind of counterintuitive
why'd they do that why do these mass
shooting happen well I mean maybe
there's a reason but why aren't we
talking about it seriously
well because I think because because you
maintain more control if you can control
the narrative you can't control the
narrative when you have the truth
because the truth will supersede The
Narrative if the narrative doesn't line
up with the truth so of course I'm going
to Shield you from the truth so I can
control the narrative and get you to do
what I want yeah that's exactly right
but in democracy you can't lie to the
population okay that's not allowed
because it's it's a self-governing
country so you can't do that but they do
do it Colleen where I appreciate you
coming on tonight thank you subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight